now fared gameplay has always been a
requirement of multiplayer games
although it didn't always start that way
see back in the early 90s video game
players were actually able to tweak some
of their parameters to get an unfair
advantage quake players for example
would actually lower their resolution on
the graphics card to the lowest quality
setting reducing the amount of
processing time required to process a
frame so they would actually get higher
frame rates another good example that
I'm not really you know bitter about or
anything was my quake clan actually lost
the last round of a very expensive
tournament because all of us were on
dial-up while the other team was all on
DSL again this was back before cable
modems again not that I'm bitter about
that the point is that unfair gameplay
makes it bad for everyone and then makes
bitter people get balled since then
multiplayer games have actually done a
lot to reduce this kind of cheating and
unfair advantage but it is something
that we had to worry about inside of
grits see if you're actually using Mouse
controls you have a lot more degrees of
freedom because there's more resolution
to it than someone who's playing on a
four pad keyboard we decided to actually
attack this for grits because some of us
were bitter about losing unfair games in
the past and actually lock the mouse to
the same directional output that you get
from a keyboard ensuring that both
players actually have a same and fair
chance to play now your designers should
mostly take care of this but if you're
one of those types likes design and
program make sure you start from the
beginning
worrying about fair gameplay or you
could create someone like this